the commissioner actually addressed the
conference call yesterday and had some
things to say
about social justice and other topics
and uh let's address some of those
things chris
as it relates to
the social justice issue
and players protesting specifically
during the national anthem the
commissioner said
that uh basically he continues to
support
the idea of players doing what needs to
be done
to shine a light on the issue of social
justice and the nfl is committed and
that's great and that's fine and that
echoes what roger goodell said a week
and a half or so ago on the
uncomfortable conversations with the
black man digital series with emmanuel
acho but but to me that just continues
to highlight the disconnect between what
the commissioner says and what jerry
jones is trying to do and jones was on
105.3 the fan yesterday for the second
time since last tuesday and the world
has changed a lot since last tuesday
yeah
the world has changed dramatically as it
relates to sports and social justice and
player protests now the protest issue
isn't taking a knee during the anthem
it's taking a seat not even entering the
game
and twice jones has been on 105 3 the
fan since last tuesday and neither time
was he asked about his stance on the
anthem on whether or not he's still
trying to compromise and i'm starting to
think that they're telling 105 3 the fan
don't ask
don't ask that question right of course
and that's why i say uh oh they're
telling they're telling 1035 not to ask
the question he doesn't know what he
wants to do yet he's afraid of
the backlash he might get from
you know
white racist america sorry i don't know
any other way to say it sorry that's
just the way it is i and then that
bothers me i don't know how you can
really squash that right of players they
have the right to kneel
it's not about the flag
so many of these guys that have kneeled
and are at the front of this
conversation have family that has served
or are police
policemen
so it's not about that it's way bigger
than that and yes there's an issue and
i'm glad to see roger goodell you know
stand steadfast with his message it's
about time the nfl they're late to the
game here so it's good that it seems
like they're going to finally back up
you know the black players in the league
and just the players in the league in
general here for a subject that we know
is very very real and um
i i just hope that all 32 owners go
through with it as well and i really i
have no doubt it's just one it's really
just one we just don't know where it's
going to go right now with that football
team
other things that the nfl will be doing
to shine further light and bring further
attention to social justice in the end
zones on each end
it will say end racism on one end and it
takes all of us on the other end on the
on the back strip of the end zone by the
goal post uh something we've written
about peter king wrote about it as well
the names of victims of police violence
and systemic racism can be displayed on
that bumper at the bottom of the helmet
and you don't realize how conspicuous
that is
until until something's written on it
you know sometimes it's just that it's a
white pad yeah
some teams have the team name on it but
you know i think peter had a and it's
not an actual photo it's something that
was photoshopped to demonstrate what it
will look like
with george floyd across the bottom of
that helmet with brianna taylor across
the bottom of that helmet that is
powerful and when you watch a game
there's a lot of close-ups and there it
is there's a lot of close-ups of guys
and you'll see those names when the
cameras zoom in guy going back to the
huddle quarterback walking the line of
scrimmage you're going to see those
names on the back of those helmets and i
think that is going to be very very
powerful but also chris it's going to be
very controversial
because
this is a polarizing issue and you know
i've gotten the question over and over
again are they allowed to have the names
on there of police officers who were
killed in the line of duty are they
allowed to have david doran on there or
there are other names you know the the
the names and the issues
that that
sharpen
and
increase the divide that that's the the
nfl
uh i don't know that the nfl truly
appreciates what it's walking into here
but once these
things and it's one thing for us to talk
about it right it's another thing for
millions of people to tune into the
games and see it because you've got
millions of fans who are paying no
attention right now yeah right to
anything you and i are saying there's a
shock yeah but you know what i'm saying
yeah i got it this is just kind of shows
watch football yeah
this is the show that caters to the
people who have a true passion for the
sport there are people who watch games
who don't have the passion they just
watch it because they watch it and they
otherwise don't pay attention to it when
they see it next thursday night when
they see the names on the helmets when
they see
and racism at one end of the field and
it takes all of us at the other end of
the field it's going to be a big deal
and
at a time when we're expecting
presidential tweets
over
anthem protests
the tweets could stray
into other topics related to it
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports